people say that it's brave to do jokes
or non jokes about [ __ ] whatever I'm
not gonna say my his name but like you
know when they're just like forgo comedy
for a while to go on and [ __ ] be
serious about something I think so but
that ain't brave yeah that's not brave
there's not taking chances you want to
be brave do today in 2019 do a
nine-minute pro-slavery bit yeah and get
the crowd to laugh that's brave try that
and see how it the heads are Korea
that's bravery you're risking something
well yeah I asked the guy one acept one
night in the front row they had a black
gentleman up there you know and I was a
you know I wasn't I was nervous but I
wasn't wild you know and I said hey man
would you own a slave you think honestly
you're chillin at home right a blood
recycle blocker yeah I said look bro be
honest be honest you're chillin at home
there's a bunch of dishes to do your
wife's out of town you maybe don't know
how to do dishes or you don't like doing
oh yeah are you watching the game yeah
Sunday there's three games in a row
you're watching the game and the game is
just two people just kicking a ball back
and forth outside right cuz it's the
1800s all right somebody got a pack of
marbles but still you're watching the
game and some guy goes door-to-door was
like hey got these cool slaves and the
slaves are cool they're smiling
you wouldn't you would not where he
hasn't color on it yet yeah just said
people yeah we got these slaves probably
Asian you know Korean a little we know
some beautiful Korean you know take a
bus space as loves you know yeah would
you get one I think I would I treat it
well but then no I am I would treat it
well for a while but then once they
[ __ ] act up you gotta lay the law down
guys you bring it on yourselves oh you
think I want to treat you like this you
bring it on yourself I want to be a good
master yeah I am a man of constant
sorrow like you would have been good in
that but yes here's the thing there's
something about you like you would get
if the guy didn't know anything you
would get a couple a badge if everybody
was getting slaves at the time of course
we got slaves you wouldn't you wouldn't
be the one who like I'd be you know more
woke than everybody based on my [ __ ] off
do you think you would be a good slave
beyond
dude well let me think okay I'm not
physically I'm not the best I could do a
lot of like mental work for you okay you
know like the way didn't Shaun shank
with he was like hey you
you were drew counting come you're gonna
work in the office the books me yeah I
wouldn't run I would accept that I have
no power I'd be pretty fast to that I'd
see somebody get whipped and stuff I'm
like oh I get it no I that'll happen to
me too right yeah right now I'm yeah I
get a killer enough to know that there's
no way out I might be looking for an
escape plan but I'm waiting for awhile
and a few people escape and then see how
that plays I'm not trying to be the
frontlines and escape yeah you're not
trying to be the [ __ ] first guy out
there yeah I think I could easily do I
always say ma'am to people who were
helping me you know not even older women
just like people to the airport like do
you ever tickets like a Mega Man yeah I
could be respectful yes sir I get it you
run the household yeah well my dad
taught me well yeah I'm hoping to get a
piece of cake at Christmas I'm [ __ ]
all the better
yeah I know you don't have to do that
sir yeah I really appreciate that thank
you sure he's not my boy that's
crazy-making you it's just wow that
things happen but it's also it's like
something just goes one favor it's my
wife and I anniversary on next Thursday
could you just like just for one day not
rape her
yeah just that one day it'd be really
cool either that fresh morning with the
layout yeah just let me have a shot at
her let us sleep in a little I'm not
saying don't worry bro at all just that
one day yeah but a sleep till 6:15 a.m.
if you don't move it again if it's if
it's in a shoot yeah you know it's
obviously it's your call but yeah I
would love that Duke it out crazy
that must have been I mustn't even know
you cannot imagine I can't imagine that
date I would hate that kind of [ __ ] I
don't like getting up early that much
that would suck that part would suck
yeah I'd like to sleep in
I'll be like how about I'm like uh like
uh you know till 4:00 a.m. slave you
know I wake up at 11:00 know that night
[ __ ] whether I like the night you know
there's less distraction oh yeah get
more [ __ ] done you don't bump into other
slaves yeah you're right there on the
porch ready to rock yeah like uh yeah
he's with ya they wake up in the morning
like what who bailed all this hey yeah I
did your honor
yep
I know it's crazy as my sister can't
even read but what does it have to do
with us right now hope you enjoyed that
video and you can watch another and you
can watch this one you can watch this
one different options different choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy two options watch one this one